les usagers ne se bousculent pas aux
tourniquets les sièges sont souvent
vides et les sous n'entre plus dans les
coffres des vignes je le prends en aux
500 millions de dollars là c'est
impossible c'est ingérable
les municipalités doivent aussi augmenté
leurs dépenses en sécurité et on santé
publique russe des opérations policières
depuis le début le jeu seul à gatineau
le ses 350 milles le temps
supplémentaire
c'est de l'argent qui est moins d'argent
qui entre plus d'argent qui sort alors
que les municipalités n'ont pas le droit
d'enregistrer des déficits d'un bout à
l'autre du pays
les villes se prépare à prendre des
décisions draconiennes imposées
augmentation peut être aux aux impôts
foncière c'est là pas sensibles ce n'est
pas possible
j'ai dû mettre à pied quatre mille deux
cents employés municipaux explique le
maire d'edmundston
ça me brise le coeur la situation est
critique selon la fédération canadienne
des municipalités qui estime que les
villes ont besoin des d'urgence de 10 à
15 milliards de dollars
justin trudeau reconnaît les défis des
villes mais il demeure prudent il ne
veut pas empiéter sur les
responsabilités des provinces fédéral
sera là comme partenaires pour appuyer
les provinces dans le travail qu'ils
doivent faire pour appuyer lives et les
maires craignent de faire les frais
d'une dispute de juridiction et d'être
pris entre l'arbre fédéral il est corse
provincial c'est un peu ce qu'ils
m'insultent le plus parce que d'un côté
on reconnaît qu'on ait des grenades
proximité ont dû convaincre des
partenaires puis leur carrière à une
facture qui vient avec son bain on ne le
dit vous êtes des créatures des
provinces
sinon avertissent lhimer ce sont les
citoyens qui en paieront le prix
soit je vais devoir couper dans les
services ou augmenter les taxes ou les
deux et pour moi ce serait
terrible les maires insiste des
municipalités en santé seront essentiels
pour une éventuelle relance économique
les villes offrent des services de
proximité aux citoyens mais elles ont
l'impression d'être tenus à l'écart par
les autres paliers de gouvernement ici
christian noël radio canada ottawa